منحه جديد استشهدوا العلاقات السعوديه
الامريكيه خلال الفتره المقبله وفقا
لصحيفه ول سترينج التي كشفت ايضا عن
مسؤولينا امريكيين قولهم بان اداره
البايرن تتحرك لتكثيف التنسيق الامني مع
الرياض لمواجهه تهديدات ايران في العام
الجاري 2023
اشار المسؤولون الى بوادر على تحسين
التعاون بين الولايات المتحده والسعوديه
في الاسابيع الاخيره من خطاء او مع انخفاض
اسعار البنزين في الولايات المتحده
وانتهاء انتخابات التجديد النصفيه التي
جاءت افضل من
المتوقعين وبينت الصحيفه للرياض واشنطن
ستمضيانما في مشاريع عسكريتهم
واستخباراتيه جديده والجهود حساس الاحتواء
ايران وسط جهود متعثره لاحياء الاتفاق
النووي الدولي مع طاهرا
من مدينه هيوستن الامريكيه ينضم الينا
الباحث في الشونه الامريكيه احمد الحنطي
سيد احمد مرحبا بك معي في نشره الربع
من خلال متابعتك هل هناك بوادر حقيقيه
لماذا ذهبت اليه الويل ستريت جورنال وهي
ليست الاولى ربما اكثر من صحيفه كانت
تتحدث عن مثل هذا التغير في الموقف
الامريكي تجاه العلاقات مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
نعم هذا صحيح هناك عده تقارير ظهرت خلال
يعني منذ انتخابات
وحتى قبل بين فتره واخرى تظهر تقارير من
هذا النوع تؤكد وجود مثل هذه التحركات
يعني ما يجب ان ننتبه له ان العلاقات بين
السعوديه وامريكا هي علاقات مصالح
استراتيجيه مهما مهما تدهورت هذه العلاقات
هناك احد عندنا لا تنخفض عنه ابدا لان كل
البلدين لديهما مصالح يحتاجها لتحقيقها
بتعاون مع البنات الاخر لكن ما الذي يمكن
ان يدفع واشنطن اليوم الى اعاده هذه
العلاقه الى اقامه مشاريع عسكريه
واستراتيجيه واستخباراتيه ايضا جديده
وجهود حساسه بين قوسين كما جاء في في
صحيفه الوسطريت
يبدو ان يبدو ان الام يعني الامريكيين
بداوا يصلون الى قناعه انه لن يمكن احياء
التفاقه النوم اوي فبالتالي هم يحتاجون
الى زياده الضغط على ايران خلال الفتره ما
بعد الاتفاق النووي هذا الضغط يحتاج الى
تواجد يعني يحتاج الى تعزيز التعاون مع
الحلفاء امريكا في المنطقه بحيث تستطيع
امريكا
بالتعاون معه الذين يريدون هذا الشيء يعني
هذا هدف مشترك الضغط على ايران باستخدام
العصا بدون وجود شجره الاتفاق النوويه
بهذه الحاله التي تحتاجنا العصايه يكون
اقوى اقوى طيب هل يمكن ايضا اخذها من جاء
اخرى كما يرى البعض من المراقبين ربما
بانه هذا للطمئنه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الخليجيين في حاله الاتفاق
النووي مثلا هل يمكن اخذوا من هذه الزاويه
ما سمعناه قبل بدايه المفاوضات على
الاتفاق النووي ان الامر اصلا كل الاتفاق
هذا سيتم بالتنسيق مع دول المنطقه انهم
حتى لو لم يكونوا طرف مباشر في المفاوضات
فانه يتم التنسيق معهم على كل شيء
يعني همم قبل قبل تقديمها وقبل توقيعها
نحن يعني كمتابعين لا نعرف ان كان هذا
يحدث فعلا ام لا ولكن لا اظن ان الظن ان
تتم بهذا الشكل انا اعتقد ان اذا كانت
الهدف الطام انا فهو سيتم بشكل اخر هذا
يدل على يعني لا نستطيع الجزم ولكن انا
نامي الى انه فعلا الاتفاق في طريقه للموت
هناك مباشره على ذلك هذا ليس المؤشر
الوحيد لذلك هذا الاحتمال بالتالي كيف
يمكن النظر الى الطبيعه هذا التحرك وفق
همم هذا همم التوصيف يعني بان هناك مشاريع
عسكريه واستخباراتيه جديده وجهود حساسه ما
معنى حساسه هنا يعني
اعتقد ان هذه تعني نقل معدات عسكريه الى
مناطق يعني الى مناطق معينه هناك تقرير
سبق ان ظاهر في الغور السرير قبل فتره
طويله عن نقل معدات عسكريه الى شمال وغرب
المملكه العربيه السعوديه يعني وبناء
قواعد ااه اضافه الى انه يبدو ان هناك
يعني الرفع في التعاون الاستخبارات ضد
ايران من معروف ان هناك تعاون استخباراتيا
ضد الارهاب بين يعني غالبيه الدول المنطقه
ومنها السعوديه وامريكا بس يبدو انه هناك
زياده في هذه الجهود نحن نعرف ان التعاون
العسكري والامني بين امريكا وبين السعوديه
عالي ومستمر ولكن يبدو انه سيتم فتح ملفات
جديده ضمن هذا التعاون يعني كان قد تحدث
في همم قبل زيارته الى المنطق عن فكره
اعاده تشكيله تواجد العسكري الامريكي في
الشرق الاوسط من خلال تجميع مظله امنيه
تمتد من اسرائيل عبر الخارج هل يمكن ان
يندرج من هذا التحرك الان هذه الفكره
من الواضح ان هذه الفكره ماتت قبل ان تولد
لانه دون المنطقه
رفض يعني وضعت خط احمر انه لا يمكن
التعاون العسكري مع اسرائيل لا يمكن
السماح لاسرائيل بالدخول في تحالف لدول
المنطقه سواء كان بامريكا او بدونها
حتى الدول حتى الدول التي وقعت يعني
اتفاقيات سلامه مع اسرائيل في الامارات
والبحرين ابدت رفضها لان نتقبل مثل هذا
الشيء لذلك متى هذه الفكره وقد يكون هناك
محاوله لايجاد بديل يعني نوع بديل من
التعاون بحيث انه لا تكون في اسرائيل
وبنفس الوقت يمثل الضغط المطلوب لانه
امريكا تريد اعاده تواجدها في المنطقه
بدون ان تكثف وجود قواتها بالتالي هي
تحتاج الى
تعزيز جوانب معين يعني معينه من القوه لدى
حلفائها بحيث انه يكون بينهم تنسيق وتعاون
لتحقيق الاهداف المشتركه بدون تواجد عسكري
يعني بدون وجود جنود على الارض
هذه التصريحات سيد احمد اتت ايضا بعد
التقارير يعني ايضا كتبت او نشرت في بعض
الصحف الامريكيه
منسوبه الى الاستخبارات الامريكيه او
مسؤولين فيها عن تطور في العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه بين بين موسكو وطهران قد يصل
ربما الى استراتيجيات الدفاعيه همم او
تحالف دفاعي هل يمكن وضع هذا التحرك
الامريكي ايضا كخطوه استباقيه ربما مثل
اللي مثل هذا التحول في العلاقات بين بين
روسيا وايران
العلاقات العسكريه بين روسيا وايران
ليست جديده يعني ربما تزايده مؤخرا بسبب
حاجه روسيا الى ايران يعني في الماضي كانت
ايراني التي تحتاج الى روسيا العسكريه
بشكل حصري اليوم اصبحت روسيا تحتاج الى
ايران بسبب نقص الدخائر لان الحربه مع
اوكرانيا استنسفت مخزون الذخائر فاصبحت
تحتاجه الى الصين الى ايران في تمويدها
بالذخائر فبالتالي يعني ظهرت هذه التقارير
عن ازدياد هذا التعاون لا شك لا شك ان
المخططين الاستراتيجيين في كل دول العالم
ينظرون الى كل شيء ويحاولون يعني احتياطات
وما يكون هذا احد العوامل الدافعه ولكنه
ليس ليس دافع الرئيسيه ليس هو الهدف
الحصري لهذه التحركات هو ربما يكون عامل
مساعد لا اكثر
في المقابل كيف يمكن تصور موقف الكونجرس
الذي يعيش ربما حاله من الفوضى اليوم كما
يرى الكثير من المراقبين في ظل الفشل تلو
الاخر في اا يعني تعيين رئيس جديد له
وهناك الكثير ربما وبعض المشرعين والنواب
الذين تحدثوا عن اجراءات انتقاميه من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ضمن مشاريع
معينه تهدف الى منع مبيعات الاسلحه وغيرها
الغال
وهم غالبا اقصى اليسار من يخرج تصريحات
يعني همم تهاجم السعوديه او تتواعد
السعوديه حتى عندما تفعلها الاداره يعني
حتى عندما يصرح ايضا مثل هذه التصريحات هو
يفعلها فقط لاسترضاء اليسار بشكل مؤقت
دائما هذه تصريحات قبل الانتخابات مباشره
وتموت بعد الانتخابات مباشره ولكن اقصى
اليسار لا يملك الان اي سلطه في الحقيقه
بخصوصا بعد فقد اغلبيه في مجلس النواب
مجلس النواب سيكون تماما من خلال السنتين
القادمه سيشل معه الكونجرس همم العمل
الخارجي والعسكري سيكون يعني عاده انه
يكون 80 90% بيد السلطه التنفيذيه ممثله
بالرئيس الوزراء وعشره 20% بالكونس ربما
خلال السنتين القادمه
بعد كل ما ذكرته سيد احمد هذه التقنيه هل
نتحدث عن منحه جديد همم
ستشهد العلاقات السعوديه الامريكيه في كل
مجالات امم في اطار يعني
مشاركه في حل بعض المشكلات الاستراتيجيه
التي تواجه البلدين لانه هذه الزياره او
هذا الموقف ياتي بعد زياره قام بها الرئيس
الصيني توقيع اتفاق استراتيجي بين الرياض
وبكين علاقات ربما متقدمه مع روسيا في في
ضوء كذلك اوبيك بلاس وغيرها من المواقع
العلاقات العلاقات بين السعوديه وبين
الصين من جهه وبين السعوديه وبين الروسي
من جهه اخرى هي دائما علاقات اقتصاديه
وليست علاقات امنيه مهما قيل في هذا
الموضوع لا روسيا ولا الصين قادران على
همم يعني تعزيز امن فعلي في المنطقه
امريكا هي الوحيده القادره على ذلك
العلاقات بين السعوديه وامريكا في هذا
المجال المستمر همم تضعف وتقوى ولكنها
دائما في احد اعلى من الجيد ولكن لو
تذكرنا زياره بيض للسعوديه لم يكن التركيز
على جوانب عسكريه كانت التركيز كله على
جواله باقتصاديه همم
ان يتبع ذلك يعني ما حدث في زياره الرئيس
الصيني للسعوديه وتوقيع اتفاقيات
استراتيجيه يجعل الامريكيين يفكرون باننا
لم نقدم ما يكفي بنعيد تواجدنا في المنطقه
بالقدر الذي نريده وبالتالي نحن نحتاج
نحتاج لتقديم اكثر من ذلك لذلك هم يبحثون
عن ماذا يستطيعون ان يفعلونه ليعيدوا
كمضعهم في المنطقه بشكل افضل بالتالي لا
يمكن ان تتاثر او هذه العوده في العلاقه
بهذا الشكل الذي ذكرته ان تتاثر العلاقات
بين الرياض وبكين هذا ما فهموني
نعم يعني الصين تعلم تعلم ما تستطيع ان
تفعله مالا تستطيع ان تفعله الصين فعليا
يعني تتوسع في المنطقه بشكل اكبر بكثير
مما تع- يعني مما من يمكن ان يكون لها
يعني يتحقق نجاح كبير كل ما حققته يعتبر
نجاح كبير بالنسبه له بالتالي ان تتوقف
عند هذا الحد يعتبر بالنسبه للصين وضع جيد
جدا
فلن تحاول ان تضغط على اي احد لتقديم اي
تنازلات اضافيه بالعكس هم هم راضيين ما
حدث ومبسوطين
واذا استطاع الامريكان ان يرفعوا من
تواجدهم بعض الشيء هذا لا يضر الصين ولا
يضر الاتفاقيات التي وقعت معها مع كل دول
المنطقه
والسعوديه اوضحت يعني جعلت الامر الواضح
للعالم كله وخصوص لامريكا اننا مستعدون
للعمل مع الجميع ولكن لا احد يتدخل في
علاقات الخارجيه علاقاتنا مع هو مع روسيا
سواء كانت في اي مجال نحن السنن سنوسعها
وسنحسنها وسنحقق فائده اكبر منها شئت امام
ابيتهم الامر غير قابل للنقاش وغير قابل
للتفاوض ليس ورقه تفاوض يعني يحصل على شيء
مقابلها لا هذا خارج كل شيء والامريكيين
يعرفون انهم لا يستطيعون ان يمنعوا
السعوديه من ذلك كل الضغوط التي يمكن ان
تمارسها امريكا بدون ان تتضرر المصالحها
الحيويه سبق مارستها في فترات سابقه ولم
تاتي بنتيجه بالتالي موضوع الضغط انتهى لم
يعد من الممكن ان يمارس اي ضغط اضافه الان
وصلت العلاقات للحد الادنى ممكن يراد
تحسينها فقط والتحسين لا يتم عن طريق
الضغط يتم عن طريق تقديم تقديم اشياء
اضافيه تقديم يعني همم تحقيق مصالح اكبر
كذا كذا نحقق المصلحه الفنيه وليس اذا لم
تفعل شكرا جزيلا
هلا امريكا
شكرا لك مره